I think we got it oh wow thank you nerd
talk right off the back all right
oh and cute Francisco
yikes I mean not just the Ikes awesome
hey sweet good deal um okay so there we
go huh hi everybody
I hope everyone is doing well properly
self isolating and the time that we are
doing like it sucks I know it sucks but
we got to do it just not not just for
yourself but to stop it spreading
elsewhere as well there's a big communal
effort but don't have to think about
that today because I get to open this
pile of presents has been sitting there
taunting me since the month started and
also growing so a quick reminder my
actual birthday was Saturday's the 21st
but I wanted to open the gifts that I
got from you folks well on the live
stream but I wanted to do that at the
regularly scheduled live stream of
Tuesday so here we are
um there are a couple of things I'm
gonna do first because some stuff that
went to the PIO box because I learned
this previously where folks who send
stuff to the PIO box I've had occasions
where they have included either notes or
certain things that they did not want
read or brought up publicly so I opened
those when I got them the rest of this
pile is all off my Amazon wishlist and I
came to the house that's how I know that
first from
from Rob sent me a copy of his own comic
raynard city chronicles which if I can
find the time I might even do a review
of over on the break room but Rob also
sent me because if um if you've been
around for long enough Rob was the guy
who sent me really weird
UK snacks and this this might be
something that I do like as an impromptu
live stream this is a
choose-your-own-adventure Doctor Who
book so that might curd at some point
during the during the social distancing
now Rob did send me some food but it
looks like much safer stuff this time
I've got
ikat berry dairy milk caramel and I've
got Milky Bar which is weird for me to
see because like I've heard British
comedians and and folks do you know
reference you know the Milky Bar kid I
always just sounded so weird to my ear I
it was one of those things that's weird
for me to find out is real have you
heard about the new prequel episode of
Doctor Who that will be released March
26th are you just referring to the the
rearing of rose would like a little
bonus thing kind of like they did with
day of the doctor which no I didn't I
didn't watch in there oh that's what it
was hmm he also sent me this his little
fox which is very cute thank you rob
also a card and a note but I'm not gonna
not gonna read those on air I'm too poor
to send a gift tears or cookie cookies
are always appreciated as well and
actually you know what now that I'm
curious I'm gonna try one of these
hmm it's kind of funky don't like it a
bad way but like I looked at it in my I
immediately thought white talks up but
then really not quite huh of course I
need some water
to uh to wash it down with I don't know
if you know but after your last video
I've been trying to find and like more
of your videos the council will be
attended Thank You Ben um you don't have
to do that but I do appreciate it so
what I'm oh um I had something that I
got from a mr. L um who had sent me a
copy of wolf children on blu-ray now the
thing is I already own wolf children for
two reasons one I really love summer
Wars so I'm trying to get through the
other things that that director has done
also my daughter loves wolves so I
actually blind bought that one a couple
years ago which she loves I gave um hope
it's okay I gave the copy that you sent
me to Liz cuz I do think she'll like it
and actually some of the students that
she teaches would probably like it as
well so I think she might even be able
to recommend it to some of them so that
would be very cool
do you own any movies from The Criterion
Collection I feel like I have one or two
I can't remember off the top of my head
I'm not I'm not that much of a collector
so I don't I don't keep track of like
the editions of things that I have can
we expect more Buffyverse videos in the
future um at some point like no promises
on when or what topic however next month
on the tough like a girl podcast that I
do with Liz we are going to do Frey
which was just
we is first on the Buffyverse so there
is that
do you like musical do I like musical
theater I was I was a theater geek in
high school yes I like musical theater
oh it was another thing that was sent to
me the peel box and if there was
anything else sent to the do box that I
received and I'm not showing I forgive
me I tried to put it all in one place
but it's also me so but got this yeah
that was very cool very neat I die these
kinds of crafts are cool like I
especially I've always loved how it
looks like like pixel art I've always
enjoyed that oh okay so next I've got a
couple of things that were sent to the
peel box so I know who these are from
these are from Carolyn who is our
wonderful mod I've been on a Sweeney
Todd kick lately send out please show
her a stage show or movie cuz I actually
am okay with the movie a lot of theater
geeks aren't you always attempted to a
British accent with Doctor Who and Harry
Potter tried doing Jodie's I dare you
I'm not sure I have oh my goodness
those are those are enticing my first
thought is I'm gonna wear these at
Vermont pride if if parades are allowed
to happen by the time that rolls around
but oh that's that ah see what else we
got here do you watch Lucifer I did I
did the other three or four episodes it
just didn't grab me I don't know what it
was I I wish I had liked it but
Slytherin sorcerer sleeves
oh nice so sort of almost kind of arm
warmer things yeah nice because
yes I despite my reservations about JK
Rowling as person I do enjoy my
Slytherin gear did knives out
rehabilitate Rian Johnson for you Ryan
Jeong look Rian Johnson didn't need
rehabilitating for me the man's not a
bad director he did with Star Wars what
he does with everything he deconstructed
it he took the tropes and the
conventions and broke them down he broke
them down remix on put the mic to
governor a different way and he did what
he always does
now I don't like the result when he did
that to Star Wars but that does not mean
that he was a bit suddenly a bad
director who needed to be redeemed in my
eyes like that
that's like anyone who says Ryan Johns
is a bad director
III I'm gonna have a hard time taking
their opinion seriously cuz he's not I
don't even have someone who does not
like the last Jedi like very much at all
I don't even think it's a bad movie
taking it in itself it's just not at all
what works for me in terms of Star Wars
and that's a complete and simple
conversation about how good he is as a
director or whether I need a Redemption
all that said knives that was brilliant
so there we go
ah if you could have any monster from
the past returned to 13 what would it be
Omega it's always gonna be Omega until
it happens that will be the answer oh so
this is the last thing from Kara when
what would you suggest to use for
watching Doctor Who I can't find it well
see the thing is like at this point I've
got most of them on blu-ray so I'm just
oh I am these are earrings and they are
very cool
and I don't think I could show them to
you because I'm afraid it'll get the
channel demonetized but it's very cool
mm oh that's awesome
oh I'm gonna wear those to a show
okay like I'm gonna show rear real quick
but I'm not gonna zoom in it so that's
that's what we've got we have kind of a
a bondage version of the hanged man if
you know your your tarot cards at all
[Music]
yes Microraptor III will do that okay so
that's the stuff that I knew who it was
coming from and now we get to the
baggages that came to the house and
we'll see what we've got here ah all
right
see this is from happy birthday the
thing I just want to say thank you for
doing what you do I'm a London sci-fi
geek watching your vids is it's kind of
like having a geek out with a mate yes I
do talk back to the screen I do that
with podcasts like a lot not as much
with videos but they're there a podcast
that I will literally pause while
driving the car to rant at the people
who can't hear me plus love the hair oh
thank you so let's see what we got
hahaha yes so this is a Scorpio pen I'm
having a real challenge of a day oh
that's my girl hmm oh that's awesome
thank you very much I had to sit through
the music man 2003 for a theater or all
I could focus on was how much Hill
teleports manipulates people and enters
people's fantasies I've only seen the
music man on stage at once actually
relatively easily like within the last
year
I want the Yeti to come back they're so
ugly although it's telling that when the
great intelligence came back and they
needed me and snowmen or the less silly
option I think it's debatable whether
the snowmen were less silly than the
Yeti was
this has some happen to it let's see all
right well first up funny that it was
mentioned knives out oh listen I'll be
watching that and is there no there is a
note hmm Oh losing my grip on things and
the other thing it Oh disturbed friends
I how many people do I need to play this
I'm gonna have to figure that out four
to ten players next social gathering I'm
at so probably not for a while but this
this is gonna get play hold on was there
a note happy birthday and Nathaniel Oh
Tracy Q thank you very much
have you watched the mandalorian maybe
some nude videos I actually did finish
the mandalorian I meant to do a sum up
video to put up in the break room um I
keep forgetting to get to it which kind
of shows you the impression that the
mandalorian left on me I enjoyed it it
was pretty good and honestly it's kind
of what I I think Star Wars on TV kind
of should be you know taking a more
specific narrow niche corner of Star
Wars and running with it and I you know
you can argue that it's a bit more a
nostalgia baby it's very much what fans
want say they want but I think there's
room for that and I did enjoy it I'm I'm
not
I wasn't like gung-ho about it but I did
enjoy it have you read any books from
the Alex Rider series I seriously
recommend the books they're amazing I
have not have you heard of the show
invader zim it's on Hulu yes I've I've
seen the original seasons I know it came
back was it with a like a movie thing or
like proper came back I haven't seen
that oh hi Steven nice to see you
people will forget the cutest thing ever
and Disney baby Perry the Platypus oh
that oh that would be phineas and ferb
which I also didn't get into that was a
little a little bit after my time here
we go gotta say that smile you're
wearing in your thumbnail it's just the
brightest thing I've seen all day oh
thank you
Thank You Valarie all right Oh is there
uh nope um receipt okay so there's no
known in this one but a fairy coloring
book cuz i do i do unwind with coloring
every now and then it's been a little
while since I've done it I think I'm
over dude indulging that again but yeah
I want a musical Doctor Who episode I
think if they were gonna do that I kind
of needed to do with Capaldi um you know
cuz they are they already had him all
geared up with the guitar and everything
thank you for agreeing on the Phineas
and Ferb I get so much flak for not
liking it that there are certain things
that like I feel like people are like
how can you not like that
and the thing for me often becomes look
I just
I'm just wasn't the demographic like I I
never really got into Power Rangers
because it was a little too old for it
I couldn't really get all that much into
the Sarah Jane Adventures cuz it was
aimed at such a much younger audience
than even the main show of Doctor Who so
yeah sometimes it doesn't make nothing
bad it just makes it so I'm it's not
it's demonstrable not for me and I can
take enjoyment sometimes for things that
aren't for me but other times it's like
no there's a reason it's not for me
alright oh tape on this one that means
get to be all fancy and flip that open I
gotta find my butterfly
that's wandered off somewhere cuz I
actually do know how to how to flick
that thing open to is this among my
useless skills looks impressive not
helpful one of the only things that I
was still missing vortex manipulator oh
nice
yep I've needed that for a while oh
maybe now I can put together either a
Captain Jack or River cosplay tease that
out happy oh thank you random um cheese
more of this
I do enjoy flicking knives open it is
fun just casually flicks a knife yeah
like I've got swords behind me yes I
will casually flick open a knife just
wondering if Torchwood came back would
you prefer to have a classic episode as
well as a modern episode what classic
monster to come back in um I know if
there are any classic who characters or
monsters that would make sense to bring
into the Torchwood the vortex
manipulator could also work for Missy as
cosplay she did use it that is true
where'd you get your glasses from they
look awesome
zhenia optical ze n ni it's an online
site I prefer color my number on my
phone apps now CI big fingers and so
doing it on my phone is often
frustrating I celebrate your happy
birthday celebrate your patreon Oh
some very much okay so let's see also I
love when they come in these bags
because I reuse these come Christmas
because I cannot wrap presents worth a
dang haha speaking of because I
mentioned earlier if someone had sent me
wolf children same director is this
Mirai which I heard very good things
about I definitely want to see I like of
the other other things from this
director Mamoru Hosoda on some rewards
is still my favorite but like I'd love
wolf children I love the girl who ran
through time and I'm excited to just
check out the rest of his filmography
will you ever do a fan meetup in the
future after the world is into ending I
mean I I would like to the the issue
just becomes a matter of like where does
that happen
I don't live somewhere that is any kind
of central kind of location like near
anything I live in them I live in the
northeast corner of nowhere and yeah I I
had considered trying to organize
something like that at Gallifrey one but
it just felt a little a little more
self-indulgent than I was prepared to do
but like I'm in I'm down with the theory
at least not sure what happened to the
note the fairy coloring book was for me
oh thank you nerd talk um hold on I had
something lost it
oh thank you randomness which Disney
Plus Marvel show you're most excited
about I am most excited I think for
Wanda vision because it looks weird and
trippy and so I'm getting Legion vibes a
little bit and I am very curious to see
how that plays out do you have a purple
eleventh Doctor outfit I do not so even
though we are reaching the point with
overdue doctor who wear the purple coat
comes into play I don't only
so I will keep doing what I've been
doing as far as that goes hey Nathaniel
and your oh ah ah yes so this is from
Jolie and galavant complete collection
that you'd like I'm very grateful for
this for a couple of reasons first off
it it's on Netflix now if you haven't
watched this I highly encourage you to
do so but you never know when things
gonna go off of Netflix so I don't like
to count that and I'd like to have
physical media the stuff I was singing
this in the car just like a couple of
days ago uh-huh
and I am it's now I'm putting it on my
to-do list no idea what it'll get done
but I'm putting on my to do this doing a
deep dive into this focusing on Richard
because Richards Ark especially in
through season two was what made this
show took it from good to great for me I
really love this show I lost it when I
saw Bob Odenkirk and little woman yeah I
hadn't expected to see him either so
that was pretty neat um way back in days
of old there was a legend told about a
hero known as galavant I'm also partial
to Richard cuz I can he actually sings
in my range so it makes me bias oh my
goodness okay
kissing objects that were handled by
other people's hands probably not the
best idea
yeah I'm pretty sure that for how long
this stuff has been sitting in my corn
in my corner waiting to be opened the
the time period of the sustainability of
the virus is past because I haven't
gotten a new package sent to the house
in about a week
do you play D&D not presently I had a
gaming group but it kind of dissolved
when the person who ran it had a kid and
then he recently had a second kid
so if there was meant to be a note with
this one it didn't come through you have
a nice voice oh thank you
who's your favorite actor/actress I
couldn't tell you um like I can't just
single one out we're gonna have to kill
you if you sing the stinking song you
didn't win an Emmy now it's time to move
along oh oh I know what this stuff is
okay so a number of the items on my on
my wish list and I think I'd even marked
them as this were things that I mean I
have to see how they look so
you'reyou're not gonna find this out
right now cuz I have to see how this
looks and see if it comes together but I
had a concept for like a custom Doctor
Who cosplay like a future doctor
basically how I would costume the doctor
at some future incarnations so something
for me to wear so this this is a belt
which I'm not gonna take out because it
requires a certain amount of assembly to
put together this was a very nifty belt
I like ooh that would work cuz I
generally do need a belt just because
lack of hips
and I would not be surprised oh yeah
yeah so that I'll be the navy blue vest
which is going to be part of that again
hopefully all this stuff fits and
hopefully it looks the way I want it to
so we'll see if that pulls together I've
got my doctors and carnations outfit
picked out - nice I won't be Matt Smith
I got to meet him I nearly passed out
best day ever it is very cool to to meet
you know come the show if you are a
future doctor I've already tried and
failed to be 13's companion can I be
your companion yeah
we'll talk do you like Farscape if so
miss that style of sci-fi
I love Farscape I've got the whole thing
on DVD I've had it for ages it's one of
those things that I'd like to do some
videos on but it um I don't know if how
much interest there like I know the
people like Farscape really like first
game but in terms of the number of
people I don't know how much interest
there is and it would be a sizable
project probably unless I did like a
specific dive into a specific episode
but liz is Vera's companion
hahaha why do you change your camera
angle from videos to streams
mainly to loosen it up and have it more
casual this is the same angle I use for
the break room Oh enjoy your gift thank
you for the amazing darker reviews Thank
You Russell so oh oh oh this was um this
isn't for the Doctor Who cosplay this
was just this is just a piece I really
wanted to try out and wear
so that'll be something I'll have to try
yeah so there we go
I know it looks very see-through there
it there is an insert uh-huh
although I mean depending on what kind
of party I was going to could also use
it as being very see-through so kind of
nice to have the option still working on
my doctor's outfits so far all I have
our steampunk goggles I got from spirit
Halloween honestly the idea is I have is
probably extremely ugly well I mean you
won't you won't know until you put it
together that's the thing like it's
possible I will put this together look
at and go oh I hope not because other
people want this stuff for me I mean at
the very least I'm pretty sure I'll I'll
enjoy these pieces by themselves even if
they don't come together the way I'd
like what is your cup size I might be up
to a B at this point um I haven't
checked in a bed I was an a for a while
I think I might be a B now
Oh are there any special traditions you
doing your birthday I like to tell my
friends that I'm one your closer to
death whenever they wish me a happy
birthday I don't have many friends um no
not really
it's it's pretty malleable what happens
on my birthday so this this was a
t-shirt that I had on the wish list it's
got it's got sort of a pink and purple
dragon and a lovely infinite little
gender symbol which i think is very cool
I'm pretty sure I actually mean
something fairly specific but I just
like it quite a bit
I love the design I'm also putting
together my own doctor cosplay and
making a controversial move by not using
a code that it that is bold um you know
not all the doctors always work hope but
most of them have had it as part of the
repertoire that's that's been pretty
standard for a bit hey are you gonna
take your dog your daughter to see the
new spongebob movie she's not really
into spongebob so probably not will you
wash your hands when happy birthday is
stung uh do you know where Dawn's master
fits into your rankings
um I don't yet I feel like I need to see
a little bit more of him a little bit
like Jody and also be curious to see if
he sticks around past her tenure or if
he ends up being like Missy and only
appearing for the one happy birthday on
to Oh Tracy Tracy sent me multiple
things much appreciated
you missed my super chat go up oh I'm
sorry
thought I got them all um thank you for
alerting me I put together my own
incarnation of the master costume you
will
obey me if you if you think that
hypnotism is gonna work on me keep
trying and see what happens oh this is
this is part of the top four that that's
sort of a shirt underneath the best and
actually a second so I I had two best
options so we'll see which one looks
better and either one of these I would
happily wear on my own I do I do like
vests a lot and I think I look good in
them so all right we've got well I'm
pretty sure I know what this is I'm glad
that my father is doing okay even with
diabetes oh that's good I'm glad to hear
that you seriously need to bring Devlin
me at your next performance like there
is a video of me performing to that song
it's it's searchable if you hunt I'm
gonna make you look for it I've done
that number a few times now actually at
this point
ah now see you had the the inclination
of doing a future dog your own
incarnation of the doctor without a
coach me I need two coats oh ah my plan
for a doctor cosplay would include a
vest similar to the one you ordered but
Brown a Hawaiian shirt
hahaha an orange tie and shirt combo I'm
not I would question doing a tie with a
Hawaiian I mean like it's obviously a
fashion faux pas I'm sure that's kind of
the idea but like it's just too visually
busy I feel like if you do Hawaii have
to just let the Hawaiian speak for
itself
but like I've said give it a shot you
don't know if it's gonna work until you
try it
lovely coat looks like you use of her
doors to master
I probably wouldn't cause play as that
particular incarnation of the master
just out of my own comfort level I'm and
that's not me saying nobody else who is
of my complexion could cosplay as him
I'm not gonna dictate that for you just
my own personal comfort I would not feel
comfortable by doing so are you going to
do iy your own sonic no cuz I'm not
handy at all like my dream is because
there are some some folks and some
stores that I've found that will build
custom Sonic's for you but they're
expensive so I know what I'd like to do
will I do it can I afford to do it I
don't know do all the people in the
stream asking to be your companion
whereas I know it won't happen cuz
you're sick of modern-day Earth
companions well remembered Ben thank you
very much alright so I've got one thing
nope two things I don't save the big one
all right you'd be an amazing doctor I'm
totally not saying this to convince you
I'd be a good companion uh my doctor's
outfit would be the best elements of 6 9
and 12 6 9 and 12
that is an odd group to mix just the
idea of mixing 6 and 9 you do have me
intrigued and curious all right let's
see here
kinda thing I'll have your birthday I
loved watching your doctor who reviews
on YouTube just want to show my
appreciation for your work there's so
many boxes I gotta take the recycling
out after this one thing I will promise
folks if I ever like do any kind of
debut of my my own take on the doctor I
will not try and do an English accent I
will spare you all that oh nice
again this was just this is just for me
to wear this is a knit duster because I
do like these things I like I like them
just to have something to throw over
what was well there's otherwise it's a
very simple top to sort of live in an up
but a little bit no wait please do want
I want to hear it no you don't like my
my attempt at an English accent works
for my kid when I read when I read Harry
Potter to her but like anyone with an
actual ear for accents like it is on a
walking tour of the UK it wanders all
over the place it's a mess and because I
know how many UK viewers I have that is
probably why you'll never hear me do it
if if I only had like 10% of my viewers
in the UK I'd be like out whatever but
it's like a third of my subscribers are
in the UK but you said the doctor should
always be British I did but I'm not and
you don't want to hear me fake the
accent I'll uh you know I'll make a joke
out of it oh god everything sounds wrong
now ah bugger bollocks
oh no this isn't right you know okay
we'll get mileage out of it
do you think would be a bad idea to
address the fact that the doctor killed
his in the master's bully as a child in
the show I I don't know I I don't know
but it would be better than anyone
attempting in Norfolk accent I'm not
even sure I could identify a Norfolk
accent British accent after a few mm
waters okay have you considered sorting
the Masters I bet most would be
ravenclaw or Gryffindor I haven't I
think my default assumption is most of
them just end up in Slytherin just I'm
trying to think if any of them would
show up anywhere else
Missy maybe ends up somewhere else but
the other thing is the Masters entire
deal is ambition and glory where the
heck else are you gonna put that so last
thing oh my god all right let's see you
last time forgive me for the awkward
placement of my hand as I cover up my
home address in a vain attempt to
maintain some degree of privacy what are
your thoughts on the doctor who's been
off class I never got around to to
watching it
oof a big boy package oh my goodness
okay
oh yeah all right oh I'm pretty sure I
know who this is from
which would and this this is probably
not off my wish list because if this is
from who I think it is they do actually
like know me in person and have visited
my house so they have my address
okay oh okay
or there's a lot to this amazeballs bath
bombs mixed fruit oh nice
each bath fizzer has a toy surprise
inside yes because I am a child that was
a lot of packaging for a small thing
what else we got
slap it bite it what is this so
apparently these are um these are but
masks not face masks but but masks
there's the caffeine but mask for
retexturizing and detoxifying it's
called slap it and there is the
plant-based collagen but sheet masks who
are hydrating and toning called
by tips yeah I definitely know where
these came from
Thank You Meg okay for this that box was
ridiculous but these are awesome
Oh oh my gosh the tech Oh be a badass
with a great ass
and give your butt a facelift oh my
goodness so I think and think that's
everything
oh man that was those a good note to end
on
the belt in the waistcoat was for me
I'll thank you Artemis sent a note sorry
it didn't come through hope it comes
together glad you liked it thank you
very much and while I do film and TV
production at university if you're ever
in Bradford UK let's make an
introduction episode to your doctor like
I'm not gonna lie I have conceptual
ideas of what will probably amount to
about a minute to just cover like
regeneration and introduction of the
look maybe a couple of lines see that's
the other thing I know haha I know what
mine I always a tagline but what my
recurring line would be for my doctor
that's I was gonna say that's the amount
of thought I put into this I don't want
to think like I think about all the time
but it's just something I've been
thinking about in small doses for a
while I have a whole season for what I
want to do with my doctor very cool I
haven't got that far I don't have
actually store actual story or script
ideas but what would your doctor love
like 13 likes biscuits I gladly deliver
it okay I'll stop bargaining to be a
companion haha that I hadn't figured out
yet
Oh will you ever do a Hunger Games video
you go far enough back I did a video on
the on the first film ages ago
with it with my lousy camera actually
shot it in a hotel because I was
travelling at the time that I that I
shot it it's old um I didn't I
I've only seen the first two movies
never got around to the other ones never
read the books so my catchphrase would
be well there it is from the movie
Amadeus do you think liz is secretly
compiling a master costume to counter
you as we speak maybe Liz was the master
all along
possibly tell you what she's not though
she's not the Rani it's never Virani I
work for Torchwood I be a good Ally you
are pitching hard on this I gotta like
it I mistook the demon of the Punjab
writer as a sasha master cosplayer
because he was dressed similar to OHS
first costume and spy fall Oh
ooh that's I mean that's kind of funny
but I like slightly embarrassing it
sounds like as well I I hope you took it
well what are your dr. pol will Seventh
Doctor and go to America I mean like if
I ever shown anything they probably
would have to cuz that's where I am
that's where I'm stuck and I'm not sure
anywhere a drivable distance from me
passes for anywhere else how would you
describe this song where's the love by
the Black Eyed Peas as a song I don't
know that's how I would describe that
I'd make I'd make sassy nicknames up I'd
make rubbish jokes where do you get the
swords these have been accumulated over
time from various sources they had none
none of them came from the same place
twice like that one's a gift that I got
at a Ren Faire that I got it did no or
that you can't even see I'm not gonna
take it down that one was online that
one was online forget where I got the
axe think the axe was online the Cutlass
was a Ren Faire I haven't bought a
weapon in a while I think I kind of grew
out of the urge I still like them but
like I I grew out of the desire to keep
accumulating I think how honestly once I
build the weapon rack I was like I think
I'm good I like the idea of a more
methodical doctor who always wears
gloves well especially these days right
it's a good lesson for all by the way
the last few videos have shown up am I
recommended so you're
getting cut out for you to the the last
couple did okay funnily enough after two
videos completely tanking although I
think word has finally gotten around cuz
there they've started to get close to
what I normally would have expected them
to do in the first 24 hours but you know
they are they're still accumulating
views but the the two earlier videos
this week completely tanked and then the
most recent two which are ones of me
talking about YouTube and one of them
even specifically bitching about YouTube
those ones did fine go figure
check the discord ah yes Thank You
Carolyn ah as any true swordsmith would
tell you there are two virtues you want
an oblate simplicity and clarity that
might that might be why I think I
actually favor the Cutlass it's good
simple gets the job done good for
slashing or piercing nice multi-use also
it's not as heavy something I've got a
broadsword over on the on the other wall
which is a nice one but it's heavy and
like I did I can't swing that worth a
darn okay so I'm popping over the
discord be right back folks let's see
what we got here sorry ah stupid thing
gifts hmm I give you air from my lungs
and that was in coming on as being quite
intimate yes yes indeed modern
companions which would you be most
likely to snog marry avoid yes we know
three is Clara or is it um okay
snog would be Amy Mary would be Donna
avoid avoid honestly and this is gonna
take some people off I probably avoid
Rose that's not to say don't like roses
a companion but I would not
get along with her comparison like at
all I don't think somebody else
commented saying Rory Rory and Rose I
don't think you're allowed to double up
like that but cool birthday related fact
the Swedish author
vilhelm Oberg was born on August 21st
1898 my youngest cousin was born August
5th 1998 so almost exactly 100 years of
park cool no clue who that author is is
there any show that is pg-13 that you
would like to go r-rated would you like
an episode of Doctor Who that is r-rated
no no I wouldn't want doctor who'd like
we've got Torchwood for that to play
around in that world and have more
r-rated sensibility I wouldn't want that
for the doctor themself so awesome huh
my head the thing is like the shows that
I like that are in that pg-13 range they
road that line really well same with
Buffy for that matter or Farscape like I
don't think they gain much going harder
than they did and the shows that I like
that our hard are like hard like
Hannibal that's an r-rated show and it
revels in it gloriously but yeah I'm not
someone like again maybe it's cuz I'm
just um I just don't I just don't think
too much about like there being an
inherent value to being r-rated there
are things that properly embrace their
rating whatever it may be and that's
always nice but one is I don't find
inherent value in one over the other see
for the snog and marry questions I feel
I have to stick with those who would be
interested personal preference thus is
simply has to be snog Clara she snog
Jane Austen who true marry bill I mean
come on of course good choice avoid
Missy
with the dog it makes her companion but
no too dangerous very fair will children
was from me if the note was missing
sorry I missed the beginning of the show
yeah that showed up at the very
beginning so if you look at the archive
that was one of the first things I
talked about what do you think of Matt
Hardy become broken I don't know what
that means
could the timeless child be done better
Saturn on Gallifrey and the child is one
of the sister of current if the if the
timeless child was anyone other than the
doctor I wouldn't have a massive issue
with it I saw I probably still wouldn't
love it just because I don't love
dealing in to Gallifrey lore at the best
of times but it wouldn't annoy me if it
was literally anyone other than the
doctor not that it should be the master
cuz it shouldn't but that would have
annoyed me slightly less than what they
did could you do a video of mental
health on the issues of personality and
belief that you are two persons no no
because that's that's not part of my own
experience so I've talked about mental
health to certain degrees before like
I've talked about my ADHD because that's
that's me that's my life I have personal
experience to draw from but you're and
like I've touched on the topics of
things like depression as they've come
up as thematically relevant in reviews
that I've I've done but I'm not gonna do
a deep dive into any sort of mental
condition that I myself don't have
because I'm not a medical practitioner I
have no qualifications and I have no
business as expositing on anything along
those lines so no that's that's not
something I would ever talk about well
thank you poker Pope I love to birthday
I cheekily Facebook Facebook pic of my
for the fortieth as it would as
it has both Vera and who elements how
would the Roni be successfully done um I
think the the way to do the concept of
the Roni correctly is to not make her
the out-and-out villain of a piece so
what I mean by that is her whole concept
is she's very into her experiments and
the science that she does and all that
but they still made her this kind of
cackling villain which undermines the
very concept at the core of that idea
which is somebody who is lacking in
morals she is amoral she should not be
like wah ha ha that's the master shtick
so the way to do the rani right is just
to remove the more honestly the way you
do the rani right is basically by making
her in trapped from sheera that's
basically what you do she's so focused
on the science the data what can she
learn what can she experiment what can
she create that she doesn't care what
the consequences are which makes her the
villain of any given story but also
potentially makes her an ally in other
circumstances that's how you do the rani
correctly she is a morally neutral
figure and whether she is villain Ally
or just a wild card issue will depend on
the context of any given story the huge
mistake they made when implementing the
Rani in classy who was to basically turn
her into the master all over again
which we didn't need cuz we already had
the master and didn't gel with what they
were saying the concept of her was there
was what we were told about the Rani and
then it was what we saw of the Rani what
we were told was not dissimilar to what
I just described what we saw was it was
Lady master yeah it did it didn't work
oh I too have a th oh look a squirrel
yeah
hang on here's an idea for a comedy
sketch set and a convention you and Doug
Walker or confused for each other and
have to try and host each other's panels
i I still haven't gone back to the
channel awesome so I'll keep any pains
for myself but after I kind of bowed out
you know for my own conscience needed to
break from watching the output of that
channel I realized that for a while that
I didn't have a strong enough need to go
back to it that I just kind of let it go
so that's that's just and I'm not gonna
judge anyone who does still watch
nostalgia critic or who went back to
watching it that's fine
but I just I realized I don't miss it
that that much I I enjoyed it for a
while but will you ever come to a
British comic-con and meet a third of
your fans love your content and now you
have no time for books nowadays but
please check out skulduggery pleasant
hmm like the title at least look I would
love to get to the UK again I I've I've
been there I've been to I honeymooned in
London forever ago I would love to get
back to the UK I would love to
experience more than just London I would
you know I'd love to get even beyond
England I'd love to check out Scotland
I'd love to check out Wales but time
money the second one especially because
you know I I take oh I do take vacations
and trips like Liz and I go places
during the summer but and like I would
love to go to the UK but I can't I can't
afford it I just I just can't it's too
much money
what's your favorite thing to watch with
your daughter
Shira which had its fifth season
announced it's the last one but it's
coming back laughter wait for the
lockdown to end first yes yes there's
also that we are gonna have to wrap up
relatively soon when you come to the UK
you'd be welcomed with open arms oh I do
I think I asked on Instagram what time
what your doctor would be and all you
said was bit busy yep that yep
that's that is the core concept bit busy
random Whovian I see you I do still see
you and I admire your tenacity how much
would you have wanted the timeless child
to be Omega and they got rid of him by
accidentally abandoning him he certainly
would have worked better
my entire mom's fine side of the family
is excuse me my entire mom's side of the
family is Scottish so I'm sure they
could give you a room all Scots are
really nice oh yeah I would love to go
out there I would love to go arrange
some kind of a meet up somewhere with
with UK fans or I can go to it go to a
car and they I'd love to bring Liz it ah
it would be awesome it would be
wonderful but there's just right now
there's just no way I mean like I I'm
not aside from the fact that everything
is shut down even setting that aside I'm
I already wasn't planning to do another
con this year since Gallifrey won and
that was in February you know I was
looking at coms in like August or
September and I just still found myself
going like I can't I can't afford to do
a second con in the same year I just
and I love that
thanks to where I'm at on the channel
and with the patreon support that I'm
able to do a callin a year I'm
incredibly grateful for that but I can
barely swing that and Gallifrey one
really did wipe me out because you know
I liked when I did terrific on last year
that that was a drivable distance I got
to drive there as opposed to having to
fly there also the hotel was a little
bit cheaper
do you enjoy the office not really it's
cringe humor it's not my thing
plus you know the original was Ricky
Gervais and I didn't like Ricky's your
vase back when everyone else still liked
Ricky Gervais I've never liked Ricky
Gervais if you were condemned by the
Time Lords to get trapped at some point
on Earth's history when and where would
you want to be placed hmm well
unfortunately it's a tricky question
because I have a feeling that the honest
truth is probably at some point in the
future where hopefully we've reached
some kind of Star Trek Society and
things have settled a little bit that
would be the optimistic answer taking
that possibility out of it um so the
question would be if I tracked there
would I be stuck there like any from the
point dropped off living forward or like
literally like stuck in a year forever
cuz then i go 20s I got the Roaring
Twenties the problem is if I start in
the 20s and have to go forward then I
have to hit the 30s with the Great
Depression
and then I'd have to hit then I have to
hit world war ii which i wouldn't really
care for so it depends on the spike that
this is what happens when people ask me
that question I start nitpicking the
specifics and go well
this baby that cuz that's what my brain
does Oh Thank You Julie I feel the whole
lack of International vacations thing
Nathaniel but hey here's a small bit
towards the English vacation fund oh
thank you very much excited for new Red
Dwarf this year I actually forgot that
there was gonna be red to it I'm not
caught up I feel like there's a there's
a year or maybe even two that I'm
missing
um trying to catch them in the US has
been weird and wonky
did you see Red Dwarf the Promised Land
trailer I haven't as quite a young
person who has no money I can understand
not going to another con especially over
the pond
my friend usually saves up six hundred
dollars for three days and is out by
Saturday I mean yeah and that would just
be money spent um I actually do usually
do a bit better than that I think I
usually cap um on-site spending at a con
at around three hundred dollars
everything about a hundred dollars a day
i I will spend that money but I tend to
be not frugal not quite the right word
but I'm picky I don't just go I won't
buy anything at a con that I know I
could easily get anywhere else
so I'll never I'll never pick up like
Funko pops or you know action figures or
movie posters like I could get this
somewhere else but um I will there's a
couple things I will do I'll go for
low-cost stuff so like I'll get jewelry
like earrings and rings but I'll really
cap myself on one we're gonna spend per
item on that
I'll buy buttons you know pins um cuz
because they're cheap um but what I
really like to find is stuff that I am
not gonna find anywhere else which is
why this was the case of Gallifrey 1 cuz
they didn't really they didn't have an
artist alley but if I go to a Comic Con
by and large you will find me trolling
artists alley looking for artists who
take commissions at a price that I don't
feel successes so usually 35 and under
range unless I really love their style
but I I look for artists taking
Commission's and looking at the south or
in thinking who is there a character I
want to see done like that and that's
where I spend the most money at most
cons is on commissioned artwork you
versus the cat from with red dwarf and a
battle royale style I mean it'd be an
easy enough win all I have to do is put
a mirror up in front of him and he's
done we passed by any mirrors I'm there
for the day I love the cat he's great
do you enjoy Deadpool movie or comics
actually I read a ton of Deadpool comics
I like the first movie pretty well I
have a lot of problems with the sequel
favorite classic who complained
companion Jamie McCrimmon and I got to I
got to meet and now I'd suddenly lost
his name but I got to meet the actor who
played him at Gallifrey won and got my
picture with him which was awesome
stands outside your TARDIS with a
massive sign saying please will do it
may be a while before you go that was in
response to something else all right I
think I do need to wrap up I'm out of
water which is the usual sign I'm
guessing all your gift gifts are already
open given how given how you stopped
opening gives are focusing on the chat
did galavant come with its note or no it
did not even sang a little bit not a lot
but I sang a little no no battle of so
battle love style I am NOT gonna win
I'll do my best to put on a decent
showing but like no I wouldn't stand a
chance
it's a plastic surgeons nightmare
my brother is called Jamie because of
Jamie McCrimmon and my mum grew up with
that who era yes she is that holt
nothing wrong with that what's your view
on non British actors taking the role of
the doctor
not at all accent or Noah so just just
no Fraser Hynes thank you
yeah no John it's just a no I I don't
think that the doctor has to be English
but it needs to come from the British
Isles whoever plays that so I'm down for
an Irish doctor I'm down for a Welsh
doctor by not an American and even even
if you can find an American who would do
a flawless British accent I still don't
really want it my dad named me Alexander
after Xander because it was the closest
he could get to it oh uh what about a
Brummie I don't know my British slang
well I have to know exactly the the area
that is referring to oh my god the
cheetah people in your series could be
the cats from cats okay but I'm not
doing the butthole cut uh all right so I
think I am Birmingham oh okay
random whoo Venus told me to tell you
they're definitely not from the 21st
century earth please just take them okay
that's that's actually gonna be my my
cue to bow out I think oh I bought your
merchant love it oh thank you I'm glad
you enjoyed it
Disney Plus launched here today sharing
login with my young cousins during
lockdown share logins yes yes if you are
able to sharing logins is is a good way
to help other folks out so I am gonna
wrap it up
the rest of my Cadbury chocolate and my
milky bar and I hope everybody stays
safe and does the best that you can
under the circumstances it is it's it's
tough going at the moment would you do a
comparative review of dr. ho who dr. dr.
ho oh geez Doctor Who and the legends of
tomorrow um I don't know I hadn't
thought of it so yeah that'll wrap up
this one thank you all for tuning and
thank you for my gosh all the stuff that
I is now exploded all over the room and
I'm gonna have to deal with that now
good problems to have so thank you all
so much I and you know I I will always
appreciate stuff and the super chats and
the patreon it is amazing the level of
support that I get from you folks but
just having you here just having you
watch getting able to interact with you
this is this is nice I love doing this
thank you for a wonderful birthday
here's to another great year and just
remember that until next time you are
beautiful you are valid you are loved
have a good night
and wash your hands